[Music]
watch out YouTube news by JK yuku the
Facebook for creators app is stepping on
YouTube stars oh I heard about this
happening Oh for real real yeah I got an
insight information that we should be
creating content on Facebook I heard
that too yeah yeah since VidCon where
they actually I don't like creators
monetize off of it now is that yeah okay
that's good well some creators okay like
the high high profile yeah I mean we
were offered it but I got lazy
you said the reupload right you just
take YouTube YouTube Rev was trying to
do right yeah yeah so now Facebook has
launched their new app called Facebook
for creators and it offers features for
making and promoting videos while
connecting with their viewers so they're
trying to create their own YouTube
platform here and it can't be saying the
same content as you have to they're
trying to just have exclusive content
gotcha yeah cuz I wouldn't mind that if
Facebook came up to me I was like hey I
want you to only create exclusive
content for Facebook and you got to drop
YouTube I'm like cool and they said like
but here's like a gajillion dollars to
do it yeah also you can start up and
create your own content and better call
I would do it well you don't necessarily
have to drop you - this is just content
only meant for Facebook but the
important thing is the kajillion dollars
because right now there's no incentive
to go over there yeah I think they're
letting some mana creators monetize
though yeah you're able to monetize with
and then the ads are like four minutes
or four seconds or really short ads and
you can like manually quick but what
about the average peeps because I would
like to go there but if you gotta you
gotta give us incentives we were offered
all four reels like an actual contract
no not like to create our own contract
but they said that if you were since we
already have a Facebook following or
whatever they would open it up for
monetization and we could create content
but yeah but it's it was it's just too
big yeah it's not yet its beta right now
yeah yeah yeah so like it's not enough
but I think this is this is it's been a
while since our conversation but then
this is like the new thing oh so they're
doing um it's pretty cool I clicked
around and it's like they have like
series and stuff they're kind of you
know these TV shows and cooking shows
and there's that there's a talk show
with I think it's Aquafina and dumb or
something or I saw her interviewing dumb
or something like that and I thought was
pretty cool I think it's the watch page
I don't know as I didn't spend much time
on it but the cool thing is so even
though like I'm I'm all about YouTube
love it but I kind of feel like YouTube
needs a little bit of competition they
never let us know when there's an update
happening and I'm just everything it's
we have to scramble to figure out what's
a new algorithm and it just seems like
they're not very cute competition is
always good though because right now
YouTube has a monopoly so you have
competitions they have to be a little
more competitive and it's better for us
creators anyways yeah now YouTube has to
get their [ __ ] - you have a reason to
get their [ __ ] together yeah yeah but
it's it's not very it's a person it's
supposed like it's an experience that's
personal right YouTube's like yeah you
have access to our audience they could
leave comments but the company is very
impersonal because of how many people
are involved I mean just us alone we
made a millions of dollars but we still
can't get the type of respect like if I
had a business and some group made me
millions of dollars
I think I'd
I make a little bit of an effort yeah
but the thing is there there's also
hundreds of other channels making
millions of dollars for them so even if
we go away they don't care yeah there's
too many people making content so
because of that it's not very personal
and they don't have the staff they don't
have the manpower they don't have enough
people to basically deal with it that's
why you have all these other guys like
that are speaking out about it and and
they've been on YouTube like YouTube oh
geez like Philip DeFranco yeah and you
know they they have all these issues and
they're like yo talk to us like figure
this out
nothing's happening it's kind of cool
with those type of creators too cuz like
and I find it very interesting that
despite how much money they've made on
their platform which is millions and
millions of dollars they still like what
they do enough to like ya say like hey
like you're [ __ ] this up for me like
I still want to create content we're
just kind of interesting cuz usually
when you see people make that type of
money there's like none good [ __ ] you
know I'll still continue doing what I'm
doing yeah something I feel up DeFranco
I think he genuinely likes me to do it
yeah I mean [ __ ] dude
right now you know the D monetization
bug it's [ __ ] crazy with a lot of
people up but I feel even worse for the
ones that are just trying to start like
imagine if if we try to start and it's
off you know every single video that we
posted like it's not getting views
that's getting demonetized that's pretty
discouraging especially like if you
spend a whole week on a video or two and
you upload it and then within the first
hour it's like oh by the way your
demonetized it's like what the [ __ ] what
happened a man just too big that is too
big now like there's too many people to
police to you know yeah watch over and
that's reason why everything's falling
through the cracks like it's right now
why the deep monetization thing happens
like you can't really like focus on
everybody when they have how many's
creators are on YouTube right now I
don't even know I do you can't count me
they can count it we can I think for me
though it's kind of [ __ ] up in like
the for me at least I feel like YouTube
has no excuse because they have so many
content creators and so much revenue
that they're constantly receiving that
I'm just like you can't hire more people
like you can't create different [ __ ]
like
yeah that sound like that's no [ __ ]
excuse that's true like invest back into
your company I know you gain that money
so you should be able to invest back
into the creators or like I might be
sounding like someone like you know
exactly because I own a business and
then there's a lot of people that are
like they see it on the surface or watch
as it is watch and it's like no [ __ ] on
the back and you don't know what's
happening so it could be one of those
things but for me I'm like [ __ ] you guys
are making so much money but maybe
they're not yeah I heard that when
Google acquired YouTube they realized oh
[ __ ] this is not really a profitable
business because of how much people
upload how much like server space they
have to use all that stuff it actually
turns out to be like maybe a break-even
business so even though on the surface
we see millions of dollars going into
YouTube after the ad pocalypse I think
that should really [ __ ] them up so if
you look at it from their point of view
I'm thinking like oh [ __ ] we got to
figure out how these ads don't pop up
with fight videos or you know super
sexual videos or like and they release
this bot out but it's like this BOTS
really [ __ ] people up man I know is
this pump does this family pumpkin patch
video that got be monetized and I'm like
what off what the [ __ ] is going on dude
science videos you know like it's it's
all over the place you think it would
get better because it's been like this
for the past few months and you would
think there they said oh it's gonna
learn you know it's gonna learn to get
better but it hasn't yeah like we're
just taking too long because there's
just too much coming in you know yeah
and it's like I think like people have
based their whole livelihoods on it you
know because it was a working format and
that's what they expected and so it's
just kind of like it's almost like out
of nowhere there's like your boss goes
I'm cutting happier income no [ __ ] you
know I was know heads up the problem was
there was no heads up yeah there was no
preparation there's like oh if you to
was like hey there's a bot that's gonna
be release its beta form right now so
just be prepared right and then we could
have had a month to figure it out or
maybe I would have been cool if they if
all they said is hey guys you guys know
about the ad pocalypse you know because
of that reason we gotta control what
type of videos are going
and we need a machine to help us out
because we don't have enough staff in
human beings to [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
that would have been perfect but they
just release the [ __ ] and
everyone's like what's happening you
know we kind of just got [ __ ] out of
nowhere
yeah and that was just like that lost
thousands of dollars and and [ __ ] had
so much like panic attacks and [ __ ] like
cuz if my mom's like oh it's pretty cool
cuz I have been on YouTube in like six
months like I literally have a
post-dated try to come back and come
back I didn't see half my videos would
be monetize I'm like what the [ __ ]
happened I literally had no idea what
was going on and the only is I figured
out was because my money was compose
like gone really it's just people don't
like in whatever yeah that's you know
that they've been dripping on the hash
tag team zero that's exactly what
happened feel like you might give
Facebook a chances it seems like it's up
and coming I would be down but I need
like definitive numbers what was that
one other platform that we did they came
in with the contractors a guaranteed
amount of money that's exactly I think
that's what Facebook's do is if it me
knows I go there trying to be a premium
premium big it was with like Jeff Bell
same people who did who look yeah yeah
so if they did something like that
that's all that's all so if they're like
here this is here's some incentive to
leave or here's some intensive to
incentive to compensate for your
opportunity cost of having to slow down
YouTube or do whatever I do okay I'm
super down for it but if it's a good
gamble it's hard to well not necessarily
cuz this is not like you can't do
YouTube anymore it's just like oh how
about you try this new platform put
different content up see how it grows
see what happens the opportunity the
opportunity concert if we only have 40
hours a day hour 40 hours or 40 hours a
week we already dedicated to youtube
right so to take out let's say 20 hours
to invest in this Facebook we're not
getting compensate for those 20 hours
but then now our YouTube revenue is
gonna be decreased by half yeah at this
point too because like I think it's also
like fan base if our fan base is at
YouTube we're gonna feed our fans versus
like taking a chance on some new people
and it's like that loyalty to like we
develop a connection with people who are
on this platform so it's like I'm not
gonna just jump ship and like bail out
of these dudes I've been supporting this
is day one you know it's like
yeah I mean YouTube has its problems but
at the end of the day overall I love
YouTube like 100 YouTube has given us a
huge opportunity and like they don't
gotta pay us but we've basically built a
company job career I think the issue
comes when you you make it a standard
and you create this program and you're
paying someone and then all of a sudden
boom it's gone oh it's not completely
gone but you know there's no
communication and and people have built
whole livelihoods and companies and
everything around this platform based on
the promise based on the promise so when
when things are properly happen it's
like yeah so I I mean that's probably
why a lot of us stay cuz at the end of
the day we love I love YouTube like it's
[ __ ] awesome but there's just
sometimes [ __ ] happens you know it's
like it's like it's like a marriage you
know like for like a relationship like
you love each other
but sometimes what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
you didn't tell me you like our channel
we also love staying on YouTube but we
kind of want to test out the Facebook
waters to see how that goes I think it's
awesome for people that have the
flexibility or if you want to do
something like YouTube might not be the
place like you want to get a Netflix
show or you wanna you know do some
series content maybe maybe it's a better
place to do Facebook approach me and
then we'll see what happens let's see if
you let's see you got something for me
and then maybe we could like you know
tango or something or whatever
[Music]
[Music]